so let's see what looks like at night
you know that is the universal sound for
it's night time sorry the giant square
Sun hello welcome to potato mode the
show where we take best looking games
out there and turn the graphics into
really something hideous my name is joey
i'm joined for the first time on the
show by Lucy James and as you can see we
are playing some was this 300 no we're
playing some Assassin's Creed Odyssey
game just came out last week and from
what I haven't played too much of but
from what I hear from everyone else the
game is absolutely gorgeous I've been
playing a ton on ps4 bro
I even tried out google stream yesterday
that streaming thing and even on that it
still looked incredible fully realized
Spartans as we could see here too bad
we're probably they're not they're not
gonna be looking like this once we get
started so if you haven't seen the show
before we basically take like some great
looking games like this and we'll we're
gonna try to play the game just with
everything turned graphics turn all the
way down and we're gonna go to any
measure take any measures that we can to
make it look gross we're gonna go to
smash smash smash smash is that thing in
the American what smash smash it's like
powdered mashed potato that was really
big in the seventies I remember eating
it like when I was a kid in the 90s on
I'm pretty sure it was a thing here you
don't need to rehydrate stuff so what
settings are these are these are on the
maximum settings right now everything on
ultra but we can actually start get
started pretty early in bringing
everything down let's
it looks like I'm looking through a
stained-glass window
it's a little blurry but not like it's
not the worst like I feel like we could
do so much worse to it so why don't we
do that before this cutscene ends we're
gonna destroy this game why not warning
we're running on unsupported video
driver Oh game if you only knew what
else we've done to this oh but here's
here's your answer to whether or not the
cutscenes are potato fide and no they're
not unfortunately oh good okay oh okay
I'm not sure where to start here there's
a lot of things going on my own fires oh
no he's on fire no you're definitely on
fire no that is definitely fired
I'm king leonidas I'm not on fire you
call me you don't fight it looks like a
dystopian hellscape oh where
everything's just squares squares aren't
bad you know
no square is it great good like Huey
Lewis knows best he always told us
I have an idea how about for the rest of
this one of our goals should just be to
just expire and kick as many people as
we can
Oh 100% also one thing I wanted to do is
just try to find the the highest peak
right one of the highest peaks or
wherever we can get a really good view
point and just climb it and just admire
the view well it's the very beginning of
the game so I'm gonna suggest that we go
to the naked Zeus perfect looks gorgeous
in potato boat and then my third bullet
point here is just be a general dick to
everyone around us which shouldn't be
hard that's fine okay do we want to be
Alexios or Cassandra um I mean Alexios
he's he's got that grizzled look with a
bunch of hair that will definitely look
terrible but Cassandra's got like I
don't know she's got the ponytail she's
got the long braid I don't see I don't
see too much of a Luxio so so maybe
let's go with him okay
oh is that our bird that's Icarus oh
we're getting a little preview of naked
sees oh my god the trees the trees looks
like a Minecraft so I thought this would
have been pre-rendered no it's not I
guess that that tells you the amount of
work that was put into the game right
did we get up here oh he's Wow okay Oh
God why does this hair look like a
brillo that's above the eyes I think on
potato mode the eyes are either a couple
thin they're either black right which is
frightening they're either black white
but in this case their skin colored so I
don't like that it also looks like he's
balding and really badly covering it up
what he knows who also I love everyone's
outfits nowadays they went with the very
bleached look also the blood Wow
I like these ones because I'm
gonna like cut these guys to bit and
then they're gonna get up in a second
and be like true and then that's when
you really kill them yeah why is that um
band like bright thing I think once we
remove the textures that the colors are
like what would we do we expose we need
to find something and so they just pick
the closest color they could find pink
in this case hi
ghost bird egg yeah okay you can see it
on the inside like I guess one of those
x-rays or you can see the the liquid
being swallowed oh yeah I just want to
see more of the the blood ribbons oh wow
okay let's try some what a lovely home
you have here thank you
did the landscape me myself did you ever
used to have one of those
like old landscaping gardening interior
design programs when you were a kid yes
because that's exactly what I enjoyed
playing when I was like 10 this is my
like precursor to the Sims right that my
dad had these programs and I play them
and just design houses and The Sims came
out I was like oh my god it's a game now
but what I'm saying is like because it
was 97 and it wasn't a game or anything
and they didn't really have graphics
people it sort of reminds me of this you
know really horrible is this the map
well I guess we have to go on by memory
right Wow okay it's like when you fly
over farmland and it's just all squares
on like Google Maps so where to uh let's
go to Zeus okay that's me all zoomed in
okay so I see what looks like at night
no that is the universal sound for it's
night time sorry the giant square son
hello Zeus shall we commence the climb
yes we have
to Ubisoft absolutely knew what they
were doing when they oh it's so smooth
when they made this the first
synchronization point yeah he looks like
he's disappointed in me
I didn't even go down to his
unmentionables
not yet his gentlemen's agreement look
upon my square island again Huey Lewis
would be very very proud of us Oh God
Marcus in potato mow days just even
worse than regular math I like how his
hair from the side looks like he's got
this really sweet and Mohawk yeah but
from the front it looks like someone's
failed a craft project let's get this
let's get our horse yeah well let's just
go kick some people off cliffs oh
they're not actually that bad I see I've
seen my ears
I think Roch when we did the witcher 3
looked pretty bad but these are okay
tell me about this horse what it's like
the horses from skyrim i'm gonna that's
that's the one no we want them I want
that one go scree Danson you can swing
your sword I'll be fine hang on they'll
be fine
yeah I mean if the the guys that you
killed in the beginning were any
indication they'll be up in no time
wait I think kids and I need to stop
asking if you can kill kids in this game
I don't believe this will end well well
says you know what's coming off him no
that's definitely blood
okay oh I went Ryan's that oh damn it
what's doing so well I generally thought
I could have a comeback we haven't seen
this loading screen yet is my favorite
glowing rectangle
[Music]
I just don't like that I can see so much
of my Cisco Oh was a flashback see he
can relate to her so well because he too
was once a bald kid white eyes and no
pupils by the way we still haven't
kicked anyone off a cliff so I think
that's gonna be our final let's find a
cliff final goal and someone to kick off
it oh it's difficult to take you
seriously what it's being melancholy
because he looks like that
oh okay so she's gonna make me go take
on some bandits so that sounds like a
perfect place
come on what are you doing are you
supposed to be following her no I'm
supposed to get what like get a quest
from her but I can't cuz I have to
follow her to her little position oh
great Oh got a whistle okay yeah but
then you come over I know I'm just gonna
run through and then they'll follow me
nobody heard that nope
that's how good of an assassin I am okay
oh my god what's that oh no they they
have these arrows that's a no one stuck
in your foot steel this what you gonna
do maybe there's like an interacting
interactable thing what's once they get
here oh oh he's on I think he's on fire
oh yeah he is so I guess it was oil in
those days no yeah so I just put it down
well the other ones gone now so I can't
check okay so don't try and kick him off
with that yes okay there's a goat
they're just reading this now you have
me wondering if we can kick goats off of
cliffs I don't think I don't know how
I'd get it there you need to like time
it so we'd run past you I mean hello
mate do you never see the ladder go I
don't know if I remember the name so
it's this video this guy playing
oh it's come here call for us or
something
and a goat just goes up a ladder and the
guy just laughs hysterically at this
goat and he's one of those contagious
laughter things and every time I see it
I just well anyone was wondering if you
could kick the goats you kick it to dad
we've we've got your answer here so I
think we should probably end the show
thank you guys so much for watching if
you have it again if you have a game
that you wouldn't see potato fide like
we've done to Assassin's Creed Odyssey
make sure to leave it into the comments
below so we'll be back again soon on
Fridays here at GameSpot calm and
YouTube so we'll see you then
I love these bits in games where they
start you off by giving you all powers
that you then have to accrue over 40
hours he looks a lot more unhappy now
than you did when we climbed on that
first let's do it spring break at the
Peloponnesian War